you
[Music]
because I'm super excited to introduce
Jennifer or export Jen as she allowed me
to call her so she's the winner of the
of the ACM Athena lecture award
it's Athena lecture and which is kind of
the the Turing Award for women so this
is this is a really really big deal and
but of course this is not the only award
that she has won she she won the grace
ACM Grace Hopper award in 2005
she's a an ACM fellow she's a fellow of
the American Association for Arts and
Sciences and a member of the National
Academy of Engineering so she got her
PhD from the University of Michigan as
it turns out in the same year that I got
my PhD so I'm not going to comment on
that for protecting my own privacy and
and then she went to industry to work
with to work at 18 T in Bell Labs and
Albert is here and so they go go back
and but of course she has a number of
other Microsoft relationships so her
students are always welcome and they
they do come and and we're very grateful
for that this is not her first talk she
gave a she gave a summer school on
networking in in India and as I just
heard she visited Victor's group nine
years ago right now after 18 T she's now
approved on the faculty of of Princeton
and and in her work she is she's kind of
a pioneer of software-defined networks
and again and you your co-inventor of
open flow and I have a personal history
with that because when I was at ETH we
we bought a a huge pile of Arista
switches and the big defining factor was
that they were open flow and that we
could program them before that is she
also worked on PGP which I also at some
point taught at ETH sure
so I'm there and one of the the most
interesting as I was googling and
searching around she has a page with all
the advice that she gives like PhD
students and so on and there was also
one of PowerPoint desks of index which
is interesting for me which was industry
versus academia and this is my last
thing you went from industry to academia
and the powerpoints explains why I went
from academia to industry so we'll cross
our our stories later today yeah so so
thanks for coming and you know thanks so
much for the introduction and it's great
to be among so many old friends so what
I want to do is give a talk that I've
given a sitcom arm our main networking
conference a few months ago and it's
about interdisciplinary research in
computer networking and what I want to
do is give you a little bit of
background of how I came into this style
of research informed a lot by my
experiences at AT&T walk through a few
example projects that I've worked on
since going to Princeton and then end
with some sort of advice for people
particularly young people that are
considering doing interdisciplinary work
both about the joys and some of the
risks of doing that style of research
particularly from an academic
perspective so just to kind of give a
little context I think you know where
all of us are living in a really
exciting time in computer networking
really the Internet is an invention that
escaped from the lab during our
lifetimes to become a global
communications infrastructure going from
this to a really global communications
infrastructure that's increasingly
critical for a huge number of
applications that affect our daily lives
and it's not only a critical
infrastructure it's one with
near-constant innovation innovation in
the applications and services that run
on top on the kinds of machines that
connect to it at the edge and the kind
of physical infrastructure that the
network itself runs over so society
critically depends on it it's in a
constant state of churn and it's a
really simple grand challenge that we
really all I think need to think about
not just as networking people but as
computer scientists broadly is that we
need to build computer networks that are
worthy of the trust that society
increasingly places in them and that
really just unpack that a little bit
means they need to be performant they
need to be reliable secure protect user
privacy be fair efficient and able the
different
entities on the internet to work
somewhat independently would be cost
effective and even reason about the
inherent tensions between all of these
goals and so I would argue to do that we
really need to build much stronger
intellectual foundations for how we
design and operate networks so that we
can build better real world networks and
also in particular build ones that are
robust to the constant innovation taking
place above next to and below them and
the main point I want to make in this
talk is that networking researchers
really can't do this alone because the
intellectual challenges are so
significant and the societal
implications so broad and that's why
really an interdisciplinary approach to
solving these problems is so critical
and so what I want to talk about is
bringing together and these sort of big
hairy audacious research problems that
arise in computer networking together
with effective solution techniques that
borrow from other parts of computer
science and other areas of of
engineering and mathematics and this
sort of style of research was something
that was born out of my experiences of
might the nine years I spent in Albert's
group at AT&T
where the group we were in really
connected the people within the research
organization doing work in algorithms
optimization and statistics with the
people that were really holding the
network together eighteen keys of
commercial backbone network together to
be able to take the problems that they
were facing in their day-to-day lives
running the network and to bring bring
those problems out of the sort of gory
details and the domain details that
networking people would be comfortable
with into problems that could really be
attacked in a rigorous way from from
other disciplines and so in the work in
Albert's lab we would the work started
before I joined but I think the the
premise of a lot of the work was that
the network wasn't designed to be
managed
right Internet protocols are really not
designed with the network operator in
mind if anything network management and
commercial interests were anatomize of
the early designers of the Internet and
so the idea that came out you know from
Albert and his group really worked on
was the idea that we could bolt on
network management on top by having a
sort of control loop for measuring the
network to know that offered traffic the
topology anomalies taking place in the
network and so on and feed that into
systems that model analyze optimize and
so on and use those results to go back
and actually effect change in the
network to block attacks to reroute
traffic to plan for the future by
following this control loop so there was
a lot of work I was involved
the nine years I was at AT&T and a lot
of it was was able to be both
academically interesting and deployed in
practice because it was sort of close to
those domain details and yet abstracted
a bit from them enough that we could
solve them in more rigorous ways so at
the time that I that I left a TMP the
one frustration I had with this style of
work was that for good reason we were
really focusing on taking the existing
network equipment as a given this was
pragmatic we didn't really have a choice
even AT&T is a major purchaser of
network equipment didn't get to control
the code that ran inside the box let
alone the hardware inside and so
pragmatically it was really difficult to
do much of anything if you wanted to do
something that required changing the
equipment but when I went to Princeton I
was interested in taking a step back and
revisiting this control loop and the
problems associated with it assuming I
could change the network and there was
already at the time starting to be signs
of an interest in making networks more
programmable including work that that
Albert Dave Maltz myself and others
worked on at AT&T that was a part of
this sort of great movement towards
software-defined networking over the
last decade but more generally I also
just wanted to engage with a broader set
of colleagues in different disciplines
on problems that I hadn't been able to
tackle the way I wanted because of the
of having an arm held behind my back by
the legacy equipment so what I want to
talk about our three example projects
that I worked on since coming to
Princeton that kind of our part of a
stack of protocols if you will for
running the network the first looking at
higher level policies making it easier
for network administrators to describe
what they want the network to do and to
synthesize the configuration of the
network from it one level lower to allow
the distributed collection of routers in
the network to figure out what is the
right way to send traffic by solving
together a single central optimization
problem and then finally getting the
data out of the underlying devices that
we need to make sound decisions about
the network I've never described these
in chronological order it's actually the
middle project took place first I'm
going to talk about that one first but
in each of these what I'm going to do is
talk about the problem we looked at kind
of a brief synopsis of the research
result and a little bit of the sort of
human side of the lesson of how the
collaboration worked so in each of these
projects there was a set of other people
involved in programming languages in
optimization theory or in theoretical
computer science in the area of compact
data structures I want to say a little
bit about how those collaborations
happened
and and what made them possible and at
the end I'll talk a little bit more in
anonymized terms about less successful
interdisciplinary projects I've been
involved in and and what went wrong in
those projects but just to start at the
middle a lot of the work that we did at
AT&T focused on optimization right we're
trying to optimize the resources inside
the network to the prevailing traffic
and I became very interested if we were
to start with optimization in mind from
the beginning if we weren't forced to
solve the optimization problem the
network its self induced could we
actually design the network to be
inherently easier to optimize and so I
engage with a colleague of mine then at
Princeton Mong Cheng who's an expert in
network optimization and he'd been
working along with a number of other
people on the idea that protocols are
distributed optimizers that protocols
are themselves a distributed algorithm
for solving an optimization problem and
that we could turn the crank the other
way we could start with an optimization
problem and generate the protocol that
corresponds to it so the jumping-off
point was the projects that I had been
working on at 18 he just before joining
where we were really thinking from the
network operators perspective of how to
optimize the flow of traffic inside the
network there we couldn't change the end
hosts we couldn't change the routers the
end hosts are sending traffic in
whatever way they're going to send the
routers are computing shortest paths and
the network operator can only observe
the offered traffic and tweak the
routing protocols so that the routers
and doing their own computation of
shortest paths might compute sensible
paths through the network that balanced
load but the more general question is
how much traffic should be sent and over
what path and what is the right division
of labor between the senders who are
adapting they're sending rates the
routers that are computing the paths and
the network operator that's trying to
minimize congestion the way that this
was being done at the time was
essentially without any any interaction
any cooperation between these three
parties and so and hosts using the TCP
or transmission control protocol would
adapt their sending rates based on
observations of network congestion when
your packets get through quickly without
getting lost
said more when they get lost or delayed
send less in order to avoid overloading
the network and the network in turn what
the operators help would be monitoring
the overall network wide offered traffic
and re optimizing the routing to direct
traffic over
congested paths and so there's a bit of
a control loop happening here if these
two systems operate independently
congestion control is changing the
traffic in response to observed
congestion traffic engineering is
changing the routes in response to
observe congestion and they're each
optimizing a slightly different thing
and so several things go wrong here
there's often a time scale separation
where traffic engineering was taking
places on the time scale of hours or
days so there was often slow adaptation
to decouple these two control loops and
also a sort of one-size-fits-all view
where the network administrator would be
trying to in general just minimize
congestion rather than realizing that
different applications over the network
might have different notions of utility
for what they want the network to do so
we took inspiration from a body of work
that came out of work from Frank Kelly
and Steven Lowe and others looking at
protocols as distributed optimizers and
so I'm gonna just walk you really
briefly through through the basic idea
in that work that focused a lot on TCP
itself so the idea is that the
transmission control protocol is solving
an optimization problem where traffic is
being sent over a route at a particular
rate from a particular sender and the
idea is that sender wants to send
traffic at a higher rate to get higher
utility but with diminishing returns
so as the sending rate is higher and is
delivered over the network the users
happier and happier but they're the most
happy when they go from getting nothing
to getting a little bit more and
gradually there's diminishing returns as
they get higher and higher bandwidth
this is sort of a concave curve of
utility and that the beautiful work that
Stephan and Frank Kelly did and others
was to recognize that what TCP is doing
even though the early designers at tcp
didn't realize it was solving a utility
maximization problem where you're
essentially trying to maximize the total
utility over all senders subject to
these curves and subject to constraints
on the capacities of the link in other
words if we have two flows one and two
they're going to have to share that link
l that has some capacity C on they
should do so in a way where they
maximize the total utility across the
two users giving each of them the
bandwidth whoever needs it most
relative to them to the utility this
would have been back let's see
rania early 2000s yeah because in 99
2000 B
I chaired it and I said study looking at
the future of Papua stick models of the
Internet and Scot Shankar and a whole
gang was saying don't touch and don't
think about tcp/ip we don't know how it
works if you try to do coordinated
controls you just gonna mess things up
so let's let's go with the lightweight
approach and that was the kind of theme
back then like stay away hands off you
know the cross at a distance don't
optimize just go away and I guess things
that changed in the early 2000 yeah yeah
I think I think basically at the
beginning it changed in a way of being
reverse engineering I was like hey we
have this sort of cottage industry of
various versions of TCP all named after
geographic locations TCP Reno Tahoe
Madison etc all of these were eventually
reverse engineered to follow in this
friendly essentially a really beautiful
body of work and the they all different
exactly what shape that utility function
has and there's a really beautiful
connection to the notion of alpha fair
utility functions and I've net we're in
economics and all the different variants
of TCP that are prominent have been
translated into what number alpha best
describes a utility function is actually
quite lovely and I don't think it's a
coincidence I mean the the the hackers
if you will that got TCP working without
the benefit of this this theory we're
doing something based on intuition that
kind of mimics it but it's really lovely
that it there's sort of a collapsing of
the the literature on TCP end of this
nice this nice framework so the basic
idea at the time I joined Princeton a
number of people were starting to turn
the crank the other way right can we
start with this
you know definition of utility functions
and generate new versions of TCP and
Stephan load generated one called fast
that gave TCP for really long distance
networks where you have you know very
slow feedback coming back from the
network and so on so the jumping-off
point for me and mum was to think well
what if we wanted to control not only
the sending rate but also the path so we
wanted to solve the entire traffic
engineering problem in a unified way so
what we started with was very much the
same same idea the only thing now is we
have an extra degree of freedom instead
of controlling the sending rate on a
given path we have the ability to
control sending rates on multiple paths
on behalf of a single sender so we still
want to maximize the same notion of
utility but the routing itself is a
variable so there might be let's say in
this case two paths through the network
for this sender and I have the option to
set the rates on both of these paths so
that the total utility is defined by the
sum
of them and I want to be able again to
arbitrate who gets access to which paths
and at what rate collectively so think
of this as trying now to solve the
traffic engineering routing and
congestion control problem in a single
unified way and so what did we do well
we we used the same kind of optimization
decomposition techniques that the
previous work on TCP had used to
translate that single central
optimization problem into a distributed
solution in the form that it takes is
that every link computes a price based
on its observed own local observed load
that's an indication of the amount of
loss for example taking place on this
link because the link is over capacity
imagine sending up that feedback to the
sender and the sender will solve a local
optimization problem to update the path
rates basic idea think of it as I want
to send more because I get more utility
when I do but the more I send the higher
the price I pay because the price I pay
is the load I send times the price of
the path I'm on and so if my path is
expensive I'm going to send a little bit
less because I'm only getting a little
bit of marginal increase in utility as I
send more and I'm paying a higher price
so every link is locally computing
prices every sender is locally solving
an optimization problem to find the
sweet spot between sending more to get
more utility and sending less to pay a
lower price yes how sensitive are these
solutions and parameters to the
assumptions about the utility curves do
you measure utility directly you measure
the cursor F get used to the
optimization you just assume the curves
approach we're starting with a word
we're designing with a particular
utility function that's how sensitive is
what you do to the assumptions of that
curve it is relatively sensitive you
want to pick something that has the the
shape you want because the converge as
long as the optimization problems convex
yeah when it comes to the parameters of
the curve is this very sensitive to that
and you have to check that and actually
we just go with the assumptions you see
so there is a sensitivity I'm not sure
I'm getting quite at your question there
is a sensitivity in convergence of time
and that was one Alka and I'll come to
that in a few slides that the sort of
brute force kind of approach of just
doing decomposition and and running and
set being quite sensitive to it can
often converge very slowly
even though it is sort of provably
optimal and will converge it might
converge very slowly and so we found
this sort of straightforward application
of this technique didn't didn't produce
effective results by itself so so the
basic idea then is now we've got a
single central optimization problem
that's being solved by each of the links
and each of the sender is doing its own
local computation so the next question
we cared about was well what if we have
multiple classes of traffic each with
different performance goals so you might
imagine some traffic cares about it
through put some cares about latency and
you might have different utility
functions for those different traffic
classes and you might imagine that the
links have a share of bandwidth
allocated to one and a sheriff bandwidth
allocated to the other think of this as
like a green virtual network for the
latency sensitive traffic and a red one
for the throughput sensitive traffic and
you might imagine a straightforward
extension to the utility function as you
want to maximize the aggregate utility
across the two classes of traffic so
again here we can turn that crank of
decomposing this optimization problem
now in two steps one that separates the
two utilities from one another subject
to their local link capacity shares and
a second on a longer time scale that
decides what fraction of each links
capacity should be devoted to each one
think of this as sort of a form of
adaptive network virtualization the
topology is virtualized but the
bandwidth allocations between the two
classes are being dynamically adapted
based on who needs it more to be able to
achieve their utility goals so again
same basic idea that now we can
essentially design the same protocol we
would have run had this delay sensitive
or throughput sensitive traffic than the
only traffic class in the network but
but we can arbitrate between them by
dynamically deciding what shares of
bandwidth page get it's of a sort of the
second step now I think for me the the
lessons here one was the idea that the
protocol should be solving a well stated
problem this sort of sounds obvious in
hindsight right but a lot of networking
protocols were designed without a really
clear specification of what problem they
were solving in a particularly what
global problem they were solving rather
than the local problem a particular
sender might be interested in and then
to use techniques for decomposing the
problem and this gives us I think both a
better understanding of how the
protocols work and when they work and
also guarantees that come from
on optimality and convergence and so on
but in practice as Eric's question
already hinted at that isn't quite
enough right the process itself is
inherently iterative we didn't really
come to the solutions we did in one step
and so there's sort of a human lesson
here and then a few technical takeaways
one I think of a sort of research as
decomposition which is this is sort of
the way that work between Hmong and I
would go I would say I need the network
to solve this problem he would say the
math is too hard and and and this is
great for Hmong because instead of Hmong
going and working on a hard math problem
he would turn back to me and say change
the problem so the math is easy
he likes to like to put it as if you're
the professor and the student you write
an easy exam right so so it was my job
to figure out if I could change the
constraints that I thought the network
would have to impose and relax them in
some way to make the problem easier and
the Hmong would eventually say thumbs up
it's convex I'm happy we can we can
apply standard optimization techniques
to to solve the problem now so the art
in this work was not the math quite the
opposite the art was in not making the
math hard so just to give two examples
of where that concretely came up one was
that we found when we did the sort of
standard decomposition approach we did
get something that was optimal and
converged but it conversed really really
slowly and so we actually changed the
utility function we were using
accordingly to make it a little bit
quicker in adapting to congestion in
particular instead of looking just at
utility we also looked at a penalty
function that penalized links that were
getting close to their capacity this
problem on the Left maximizing utility
was what what TCP congestion control was
doing minimizing this penalty was
actually what the network operators were
doing in doing traffic engineering so
the sort of an interesting coming full
circle here that in some ways both sets
of hackers were right right maximizing
utility and keeping keeping a damper on
congestion both end up being important
and once we decompose this problem we
ended up with something that not only
was provably optimal unstable but
converges much much more quickly because
it gave an early warning when the
network was getting into an unhappy
place rather than waiting for all hell
to break loose before hand and a second
example well we're looking at that clap
multiple classes of traffic I described
it as if there's sort of two separate
virtual networks each with its own
share of resources but when we started
we envisioned there being one q1
capacity for the link and the traffic
mixing together but in practice that
made the optimization problem impossible
to decompose because the utility of one
traffic class was really intertwined
with the utility of the other to put
that in kind of concrete terms delay
sensitive traffic would be suffered
suffering delays and queuing because the
throughput sensitive traffic would drive
the the links to very high levels of
utilization and so we found to get the
optimization problem to decompose we had
to have separate queues with on a longer
time scale with the scheduling the
scheduling of them changing to
accommodate no who needed more utility
and that came out of just observing that
the math was really hard if we didn't
make that separation so it's a perfect
example where among who said can't do it
but if we actually could separate these
two traffic classes and make their
utility functions less dependent on some
time scale we can a sort of more human
lesson here is also of course anybody
who's ever been a graduate student in
this room knows that research never
works this way with faculty actually
talking to each other on a regular basis
so you should already be quite
suspicious that I haven't told you the
whole story which is of course the
student in the room was was critical
because she was able to connect with
both of us and to really you know
wrangle us and get an expert enough
expertise of both topics of network
hardware and software constraints as
well as has the kind of optimization
techniques involved to be able to
actually make this work happen now for
me a great frustration this work
happened about 10 years ago is it was
really hard to get it deployed because
again we are still stuck with the
problem I mentioned at the beginning
that we can't change the equipment
inside the network so we could do
experiment we could do simulations but
we couldn't deploy and now we're
actually just starting to have the kind
of programmable switch hardware and I'll
talk more about these kind of switch
switching capability is a little later
in the talk or now it's actually is
possible to deploy these techniques and
I'm starting to work with folks at AT&T
sort of again coming full circle who are
interested in doing a deployment of some
of these ideas to see if they might be
suitable for their backbone Network so
so that's sort of the end of the first
part of the talk if we want to maybe
stop here people have comments or
questions before before we go on yeah
he mentioned the optimization as being
the talent you were looking for it to
mix with networking but it seems visit
is a big third bubble coming in
mechanism design in economics yeah which
is kind of a different way of thinking
about distribution of effort and and
credit assignment and payment someone
I'm curious if if that's still an area
that's waiting pregnant with results in
the space or yeah that's a great
question so yes I think so and I won one
piece of work I don't have in here that
it had that flavor was looking at how
the different domains that make up the
internet interact with one another
because their economics obviously play a
direct role entire autonomous systems
entire networks are sort of rational
actors making best responses based on
what their neighbors do and their the
language of game theory is a beautiful
fit very wide open now other people you
know in the fifteen years by while I was
asleep at the switch per se that been
happening also that pentakill has been
moving I've been tracking I think Samba
mean a particular in the area of inner
domain routing I think so I think also
in areas around spectrum management or
in dealing with scarcity of IP addresses
there's sort of been little pockets of
networking where we've seen game theory
come to play I think there's a great
opportunity to do more there frankly
because I think a lot of the research on
game theory has understandably focused
on particularly computer science work on
game theory on some of the theoretical
machinery and there hasn't been as
enough of a meeting of the minds with
practical problems the problems you're
putting up here first reaction is yes
the first approach would be to basically
try to do optimization of various kinds
yeah and classical models looking at the
whole system but then there's this kind
of this whole distributing world of
rational actors that should be like
another second-generation approach to
thinking yeah
large scale populations of actors as no
it's and messages for example now that
is curious that's wide open right now I
think I think it's mid way open I think
the reason it doesn't come up here as
much is because we're focusing on single
administrative domains wherever social
welfare maximization is a reasonable
model but certainly spectrum options any
any sort of distributed scarce resource
I think it's it's very cool
and I think another another thing that's
interesting here is a lot of the work on
game theory doesn't think as richly
about
amic's sa work and distributed computing
does and yet a lot of the distribute
computing work doesn't have the same
sort of take on rational actors so
there's a I think ships in the night
problem there where those two fields
could could be closer together than they
are yeah great question
other other thoughts so I'll talk about
the the second piece of work so one
thing that was comfortable for me in
this work with Hmong well I'm no expert
in network optimization I'm at least
familiar was sort of the language of
optimization the next project was a
little bit out of my comfort zone which
is working with folks in programming
languages and and the jumping-off point
for this work was that there was a lot
of interest you know around ten years
ago in moving towards a more central
model of network control and management
software-defined networking as was
mentioned in the introduction it was
something we started working on a bit
when I was at AT&T and it became more
prominent when OpenFlow came around and
so became interested in the question of
how should network administrator's
describe to the network how this in a
central way how they should describe how
the network should actually behave open
flow itself as I'll talk about in a
moment is not a linguistic formalism
it's like assembly language it's better
than micro code but it's still pretty
low-level and someone talked a little
bit about about this project the
frenetic project that was done with Dave
Walker my colleague at Princeton in
programming languages and Nate Foster
who's a professor at Cornell who is a
postdoc at the time in our groups so in
Software Defined Networking now you sort
of pop up a level from what I described
before and now the the underlying
network devices are largely done you
have a logically centralized controller
and that is running some sort of
application that is going to tell the
underlying switches what to do and so
the two basic ideas here one is the idea
that decisions to be be made based on
network live visibility and exercising
network wide control and that you should
do so using some direct open interface
to the underlying forwarding
capabilities of the switch this is what
was lacking when I was at AT&T when we
weren't allowed to change the equipment
not even the software of the equipment
this changed when there started to be an
open interface between the software on
the device and the low-level hardware
that forwards packets at high speed and
so open flow which came out in brown
2008 was essentially a beginning of
thinking about what these interfaces to
the switch Hardware might be so at a
high level what open flow 1.0 the
original version of open flow did was to
say well every switch has a rule tape
all packets come in they get matched
against the highest priority rule based
on patterns in the packet header and the
patterns expressed in rules and the
simple action associated with the
matching rule is the one that gets
performed so a good example as a packet
comes in you might look at this
prioritized list and based on the source
IP address if it starts with the first
two octets of one and two and the
destination starts with the first three
octaves of three four and five
then those packets would be dropped if a
packet doesn't match this pattern it
would fall through to the second rule
and maybe be forwarded out output port
two or maybe it follows to the third
rule and gets sent to some sort of off
board controller so the basic idea here
and it's actually a very cute very cute
idea is that all of these marketing
terms that that networking is frankly
rife with router switch firewall load
bouncer that firewall all of these
things fall into this basic framework if
you match on the MAC address or a switch
if you match on the IP address your
router if you're doing access control
based on several of these fields you're
a firewall if you're modifying some of
the fields you might be a network
address translator but that the
underlying hardware mechanism is largely
the same a rule table with patterns of
matching and very simple actions and by
taking that interface that already
matched what the underlying hardware was
actually doing so this is not designing
new hardware it's just opening up the
API to the underlying hardware that
existed at the time and in particular to
a particular kind of memory called the
ternary content addressable memory that
allows these lookups to take place at
very high speed by doing them in
parallel across all the rules in this
switch so that was sort of our
jumping-off point that you have now this
open interface to the switch but it's
still extremely low-level as I mentioned
a moment ago open flow is a mechanism
it's not a linguistic formalism it's a
way to install rules and switches and to
reason about what those rules will do to
your packets but you're still thinking
about priorities of rules and wildcards
and bit masks and overlapping rules and
and so on making it very difficult to
actually write applications on top and
so what we really wanted to do is come
up with an effective programming
abstraction that would let people write
their apps without having to be experts
in the lingua franca of open flow and in
particular we sort of started with the
question of modularity and the sort of
age-old problem so you want to be able
to write an application for your network
but actually you really want to write
multiple you want a route and monitor
and do firewalling load-balancing and
various other things but most
importantly you want to do all of them
on the same traffic it's not you want to
route some traffic and monitor others
you actually want the illusion that
you're doing this on all of the traffic
and yet still be able to avoid building
a monolithic application that would be
naturally hard to test debug and so on
this sort of motherhood and apple pie
right you want modular the ability to
develop modular application so you can
write each of these apps separately but
because each of them partially specify
how the same traffic should be handled
you can't just run all four of them with
regular isolation mechanisms in place
you need to be able to reason about
their composition so you can write and
reason about them separately and yet
still have them act as a single
application on the single set of traffic
affecting a single table of rules in the
underlying switch so that's that's the
problem we're trying to solve so my
colleagues and programming languages
like to think about everything as a
function and everything is about
composition of functions and sort of
functional reactive programming was the
area of PL that we started looking at to
give us ideas so the first idea is how
can you model open flow itself so you
could think of open flow as a function a
function from a packet to a set of
packets so a packet and its locations
this is all the header fields including
something logical about where the packet
is at this moment what switch and what
port of the switch are at and they're
going to do a function on this packet
that will generate some set of packets
the reason that's a set is if you drop
the packet it might become an empty set
if you forward the packet it might
become a new packet at a new location if
you multicast the packet it might be
multiple packets at multiple locations
so the basic idea is you have a packet
and it's location and then you're going
to spit out a set of packets and their
locations and that's going to mimic what
operation the switch is actually
performing on the package like that's
sort of the the first basic idea and
just to give us really simple example
you might imagine having boolean
predicates that match on certain aspects
of the packets location and header
fields and then do modifications to the
packets location and header fields
accordingly to do packet forwarding or
in this case also nattie by changing the
package destination IP yeah that's sort
of the first idea the second is now
you've got this functional way of
thinking about policy you can you can do
sort of standard kinds of composition
and in particular you could imagine that
two basic ideas of doing composition in
parallel and in series
so just to give a concrete example let's
suppose I'm on a monitor traffic by
source IP address I want to view the
histogram of the traffic by sender and I
want to route the traffic based on the
address block it's destined to so I want
to route on destination prefix then I
might have one function that tells me to
count traffic depending on the value of
the source IP and I might have a second
function that wants to forward traffic
out a particular output port based on
the value of the destination IP but of
course I actually want to do both for
every package it's as if I have two
copies of this packet one I want to
monitor and the other I want to forward
and in practice I really want to do both
and synthesized a single table of rules
in the switch that will do both and so
parallel composition does exactly that
if you look under the hood it's ugly you
can think of this as sort of an ugly
cross product of all combinations of
sources and destinations and do both the
counting and the forwarding the key
point here is that the person writing
the code doesn't have to think about
this gobbledygook they just think about
monitoring and routing as independent
entities they may by their monitoring
application from one party and write
their own for the other doesn't matter
because they can really reason about
them independently and snap them
together in this way is that sort of the
first idea but many things many things
besides monitoring want to do more to
the packet than just look at it they
actually want to change somehow the way
the packet is handled that gets a bit
more complicated so just to give a
simple concrete example imagine you want
to build a load balancer and then though
there's been a number of projects here
and not to do it etc that have done
exactly that the switches can play a
role in some primitive parts of the load
balancing so a common thing when you're
building a server load balancer you have
multiple back-end servers let's say with
three different addresses but a single
public facing address that the clients
send requests to that box may be a load
balancer and what it's going to do is
select different subsets so the requests
to go to different back-end servers by
rewriting the destination IP address to
send it to the chosen back-end server so
here you can see this is a sort of
sequential operation one is picking the
back-end server to achieve some load
balancing goal among the whatever
servers are up at this time and a second
to actually route the traffic to the
chosen back-end server based on it based
on its choice and so here you could
imagine a form of like think of this is
like the UNIX pipe operator right you're
essentially load balancing first and the
output of load balancing should effect
the inputs to routing so concrete
example you might imagine all packets
whose source IP address starts with zero
that are going to a particular public
service will go to one of the two
servers and all who start with one might
go to the other this is sort of roughly
dividing in half the traffic so that
half the requests go to one server and
have to go to the other routing might be
completely unaware of that process and
just be deciding what the shortest path
is to get to each of these back-end
servers and forwarding the packets but
again of course we want to do both which
underneath the hood if there's only one
rule table in the switch is kind of a
yucky mess of matching on packets
modifying the destination and forwarding
the packet as if the destination had
already been modified right because it's
essentially smooshing together two
different functions and synthesizing one
that has the effect of both done in
series so there's just sort of the two
basic composition operators and then we
did a bunch of other things around
abstracting the topology abstractions
for monitoring the network abstractions
for updating the network that I'm not
going to talk about here but they all
kind of are in the same spirit of trying
to find simple reusable and composable
abstractions for querying computing and
updating policies on the network so a
couple lessons here open flow is an
important first step it generalized the
capabilities of a lot of commodity
networking devices and frankly for me it
was hugely helpful because I could
explain it to people in programming
languages without them running away
screaming what about one thing I found
challenging about doing
interdisciplinary work in networking is
our field is riddled with acronyms and
minutiae and it often is just very
off-putting to people that actually want
to think creatively in their own field
and so having a simple abstraction to
explain to a colleague without them
having to know all the alphabet soup of
networking was just tremendously helpful
I don't think we would have been able to
do this work without that and then from
the PIO community we really got the this
sort of taste for thinking in a
compositional way and for painstakingly
thinking really hard about what were the
right simple and reusable abstractions
and continuing to revisit them as the
work progressed and in fact my
colleagues did a really nice piece of
follow-up work called netcat which
recognized that this policy language
that I just was describing earlier and
the composition operators are actually a
lovely example of something called a
cleaning algebra with tests
which is a long and storied history and
so you can actually map everything I've
just been talking about and more into
this nice mathematical contract and it's
very useful for synthesizing networks
for doin verification on networks for
virtualizing networks and so on if you
have any interest in this face the net
cap paper from Nate Foster and D blocker
and and dextra cousin and others it's a
really lovely paper so so that that
essentially built on top of recognizing
that the abstractions we had already
built actually we're not entirely new
they really had a very nice mapping into
some existing ideas and as I mentioned
we also kind of came back to that whole
control loop that I've been obsessed
with ever since I started working with
Albert that we want abstractions for
measurement for making decisions and
finally for doing distributed updates to
whole collections of switches as if it
happens in one fell swoop and so there
was a body of work focused on that also
the the human lesson here one was was
really neat I mean so Nate did a postdoc
with me and Dave at Princeton for a year
before he went to Cornell and he
basically was embedded in my group
sitting with networking people absorbing
networking lore writing lots of painful
code on the early open flow controllers
of the time experiencing pain and
reflecting on that pain so this was very
much a learn by doing kind of project
there was a an open source network
controller called NOx that was an
enabler there because we could get
started trying to build real
applications and then reflect on what
was painful what kind of you know repeat
code we had in multiple places and a lot
of that allowed the abstractions to
follow and finally there's been a lot of
work by Nate largely by Nate but also to
some extent by me and Dave on creating
software that other people could use
tutorials summer schools keynote talks
in each other's conferences publishing
in each other's conferences that I think
helped a lot in creating a community of
people that were able to build on this
work and now we've we see in both PL
conferences and networking conferences a
significant number of papers in both
just as an anecdote there the second PL
paper that we spent was sent to poeple
in this space the reviewers came back
saying there's already been one paper on
programmable networks aren't we done and
I think we don't get that anymore and
I'm sure in networking now I hear people
complaining hey a third of the
conference's on PL now like you know you
know so I think there's definitely been
some misunderstand
how rich the problem space might be but
I do think we're sort of over a hump now
where people appreciate that there's
some really rich and interesting work to
do at the intersection yeah talking
about I hope you weren't that reviewer
they talked about people are and
verifying people or I'm curious it seems
like my understanding of sort of where
this language when was she got to sort
of like the C programming level of
specifying that you know which is a much
higher level than you start it with but
it's not at the level of sort of like
there's contracts and you can verify
aspects of the program statically
essentially so I'm curious ik do you
think that you know things went far
enough or you know is there more room
here I mean are we kind of at a point
where the network computing says if
community says yeah this is this is good
enough for us it's sort of high enough
level or if you think there's still room
for you know even raising the oh I
completely agree that there's room to go
further i mean even programming is
something like frenetic the language we
created is quite low level and
particularly when i talk to companies
who are not software companies of their
own you know not Google Microsoft
Facebook and so on they find this
doesn't solve their problem it might be
under the hood in something that solves
their problem but it's much lower level
they want to talk about service level
agreements and you know high level
specifications of exactly what you just
said so I do think there's an exciting
opportunity there to come up with
languages that talk about that and may
be synthesizing under the hood things
that can can be compiled to lower levels
a second thing we really haven't done
that's really important is many of these
abstractions give the programmer a lot
of power but not a cost model I gave a
talk on frenetic at Google and the first
thing I heard it for the people of
Google is that if you give people the
programming interface to this which they
will bring down your network and ok so
so clearly there's a need to give people
capabilities for reasoning about the
overhead of the operations they do I
mean if you create something that
creates a cross product and you have an
explosion of state and the switch or
create a policy that forces a lot of
packets to go to the controller that's
not okay and I think we're not really
still at a good point of reasoning about
the overheads that are introduced when
people write these applications and the
newer switch hardware has capabilities
I'll talk about that next that are not
captured by this programming model I
think so I think there's a lot to do to
make the underlying
data plane richer and be able to more
put more of the operations down there
you had something else yeah so I I just
wanna reflect a little bit on the
lessons learned right so and also about
your service Ematic Devon
interdisciplinary search so I think one
thing so in 1990 right so in terms of
interdisciplinary search I think this
notion of separating control planes with
the appliance were quite well
established in wireless industry for
example this notion of having dumb
access points and smart cities were
there and then what happened is in fact
I personally appeared the whole
architecture based on that but what
didn't happen is that there was a lot of
push from companies like Microsoft
itself to port a lot of these marks in
the switches itself so interpreter 1x
happened because they wanted to his
security at the switch now the reason
for that was because it was sort of
separation of labor I know who controls
what and you know from a microscope a
spectrum it was sort of important to say
well if you take that responsibility I
don't have to worry about it and so I
can go the other things right now what
happened in the networking wireline
networking space was wasn't getting any
traction either I mean Nick you know you
guys were doing it and Enterprise went
getting interaction it was only because
cloud became a thing where you became
where it became that everybody owned
their own equipment and once you owned
the equipment you wanted to own you you
want to have the flexibility to program
your own equipment because you were
being sold features that he didn't
really care about and he was paying a
lot of money for that stuff so even
though it says happening in academia
what is happening in the industry in the
business is actually impacting how
effective any of this is becoming and so
I think that as you reflect on all these
things and as we move forward I think
that has to be a pretty serious
consideration about how businesses are
moving forward and what is happening
there while research has been done
otherwise you know you know that cancer
research and nobody ever pays attention
to it and I think that when that
happened when these things are to light
up even now for example if you look at
the internet and wide-area it's these
things are not taken out there so the
question that Eric was asking about the
economics of it I think
is more on Spartan because the economics
drives that design as opposed to the
controllability
yeah I think there's no point on what
you said particularly just to put it in
context of open flow I think what so
there's a whole body of people in that
in networking there's a whole body of
work in active networking that didn't
get off the ground you know sort of in
the mid 90s into late 90s and I think
what happened with open flow that made
it more successful was partially timing
right there we're starting to be a third
party vendors a merchants silicon
companies that were selling chipsets for
building switches so you could build a
switch without being a large vendor with
its own fabrication facility and there
were cloud operators who had unique
requirements and the ability to write
their own code and that was sort of a
perfect storm and I think what Nick
McEwan in particular cuz he was really
the one who spearheaded the work on I
open flow was to recognize this was a
special moment and that if some effort
was put in place at the right time to
get the api's in place a lot of a lot of
good stuff would follow and so I do
think that the definition of open flow
was strategic it's not a it's not a
beautiful spec but it was at the right
time and had a right sweet spot of being
flexible enough to do something
interesting without being ahead of what
the hardware could do at the time yes
the fact that a lot of things that
external the community happened which
caused something to really be completely
otherwise you just can be doing great
work yeah and I guess I sort of hinted
at that a bit in the first project which
was not successful at the time and in
terms of give you success in terms of
having successful tech transfer because
it was sort of in that sense ahead and
that it assumed capabilities of the
hardware that didn't didn't exist at the
time so there was nowhere for it to go
when the work was when the work was
actually done yeah more technical
question thing but I think you've
partially answered it when you comment
about cost models because in these best
en situations it's not just all about
composition modularity even for the
examples you gave on blood balancing and
navs
yeah you have to do some at least some
arithmetic minimally yeah so what are
the limits on you know what are can you
write turing-complete
computations for example so one way to
think about it is that the underlying
switch has this very limited sort of
match action paradigm that's not been
remotely close to turing-complete
and then the controller is an arbitrary
piece of software that could do
everything else
of course that's a glib statement
because then a great cost right so
there's sort of similar to the wireless
setting that Victor was talking about
you since they have these dumb switch
devices that are fast but only have
relatively simple computational model
and then you've got the slow central
controller they can do just about
anything and what's happened in the last
few years is a revisiting of what the
switch could do if you're willing to now
say programmable networks are what I
want and I'm willing to design new
switches with that paradigm in mind then
there's an opportunity to think about
what can go in the switches to to make
it possible to do more of the
computation directly in this range so it
is reasonable to guess on this specific
work that you're talking about it
especially with David Walker and Nate
Foster involved these are fairly
powerful functional so think about the
whole lambda calculus available so you
could and in fact you can essentially
view that really what you're doing on
the network is installing a set of
functions or composed set of functions
on the network over time and and the
software that decides what the functions
should be at any given time could be
arbitrary code right and Nate had a
version of frenetic that was implemented
in oak mo we had a version implemented
in Python but essentially you could
imagine taking whatever other
programming constructs you might want
for constructing those functions and
then across apps you would compose them
and and and synthesize them I guess
Victor's earlier comments tie into this
because partly what the equipment
manufacturers are willing to actually
you know put into the underlying network
infrastructure really also put a limit
to what what's actually practical yeah
exactly an open flow is embarrassingly
cognizant of that right I mean open flow
basically defined only things that could
be done in existing switch hardware and
it tried to be as general as it could
subject so that constraint but that's a
fairly significant constraint and to the
question that that that you asked about
a few minutes ago that software running
above the switch is now kind of
arbitrary code so if you want to think
about verification that's not good right
so you definitely want languages further
up the stack if you want to be all the
reason collectively about the entire
system not just about the part that's
running in the network the gems just
about the OD deep listening spec was
good e because you guys try to be very
general right so it was very loaded in a
way that the switch manufacturers didn't
actually implement
spec right so we like when we talk to a
lot of these guys they were implementing
some subsets of these things as Peter
was saying so I guess the question is
that would you reflect back and say that
maybe you were too general in some sense
or trying to sow the OpenFlow spec
evolved they're sort of open till 1.0
that was pretty simple and then it
quickly became you know one point one
point two and so on and I think what
happened is people wanted greater
expressiveness and the switch and yet
the more that happened the more complex
the spec got and it became the kitchen
sink right the original open flush that
could match on like 12 header fields
with a simple set of actions go below
1.5 can match on 42 header fields and do
a whole bunch of other actions with
multiple stages of tables and your brain
starts to explode and some vendors
implement some parts and some implement
the other yeah no I think we've got
level but you industry got ahead of
itself and I it's understandable because
people wanted to write applications that
couldn't run efficiently using open flow
1.0 so that's the sort of other side of
the coin of being pragmatic to the
existing switch hardware and I think
that's why you're seeing now you know
new new switch hardware right that's
trying to address the limitations of
functionality that the cloud also
exactly and I think many people found
out that flow is too much and not enough
right it's a lot of people started doing
things in the hypervisor or in the neck
because the open plus which is weren't
capable enough to do more and some of
that's just because they were defined
that way because of the legacy chips and
some of it is it's really hard at at
line rate in this wedge to do really
complicated things so I think the votes
still out actually right in fact to
Ben's question about programming I think
many people don't want to program the
network they want to program the system
and a lot of this work is still you know
focused on the network right and you'd
like to think you're going to talk about
the machines you know as a pool of
resources you know the server's the
nicks the switches and so on and right
now it's still very siloed so I think
there's a lot of scope to do not only to
go up the stack but to go broader as
well so that's a great segue to thinking
about the ability to program new
hardware so the last thing I wanted to
talk about was a some really recent work
so this is going to be a little bit more
narrow and a little more focused on a
very specific technical
just to illustrate some of the work
we've been doing on on network
monitoring so the big frustration and a
lot of the work that I was involved in
at AT&T is many networking problems
knowing what's going on is harder than
knowing what to do about it
and that's often because we just don't
have sufficient visibility into the
traffic the performance and so on often
working with you know measurement
techniques that are quite coarse-grained
and slow so I became very interested in
how to leverage emerging switch hardware
to be able to do better measurements and
that's that's sort of the big focus on
my current research so that working on
on open flow and frenetic and so on also
led to a bunch of programming
abstractions that led us to rethink what
we would want the hardware the future to
look like if we could go beyond open
flow and so a number of people became
interested in us and other groups as
well in more programmable packet
processing directly in the switch and so
it's going to tell you a little bit
about how currents which hardware that's
coming out of a number of companies
barefoot networks NIC cards from
metronome and Xilinx and so on how
they're thinking about what the switch
hardware the future should do the first
is that instead of having a fixed set of
header fields first twelve than a bunch
more than forty one than forty two and
later versions of open flow there there
should just be a person and that parser
should be programmable as sort of a
little state machine that can decide how
to read the packet in which fields to
extract from it this is not a
particularly deep idea and in fact a lot
of switch part where has this it's just
that it's not exposed to the programmer
so a programmable parser and then a
series of match action tables just like
open flow had but able to match on the
fields that are come out of the parser
and also on metadata that might get
passed along from one stage to the next
now often the computation you want to do
might go across multiple packets if so
be nice to have some storage some
registers if you willed I can keep state
about history of past packets and
computations on them in the switch and
then ability to pass state also from one
stage to the next
so that sort of two big things here are
being able to parse match and act on a
programmable set of header fields and
the second is the ability to create a
maintained state state across stages
between stages and the switch and state
and registers that might be read when
the next packet comes along so this
computational model is still pretty
primitive but it's much richer than open
flow and it's still possible to run at
line rate so began the goal here
to find a sweet spot that's amenable to
efficient hardware implementation to run
at line rate and yet still as
programmable as we can make it subject
to that constraint and so the problem
space I'm particularly interested in
here is is measurement so what do we
have here in this picture is is a
streaming platform right we've got a
modest amount of state modest
computational capabilities and a
pipelined architecture that one can do
processing in multiple stages it's a
perfect fit for the problem of streaming
algorithms where you want to do some
simple computation on packets as they
fly by keep a limited amount of state
and there's actually a very rich
literature and theoretical computer
science that goes under the name of
compact data structures or streaming
algorithms or sketches that create a
great opportunity to actually realize
those algorithms now directly in the
data plane but there's a catch the
theory literature is not a perfect fit
because they often assume a richer
computational model than the one I just
presented and so a lot of this work is
taking ideas from compact data
structures and figuring out where it
doesn't work because it violates some
assumption of the computational model I
just presented and trying to find a
meeting of the minds where hopefully we
can approximate those algorithms in some
reasonable way while still working
within this which in particular we've
got a pipelines model of computation
it's very difficult after you've read a
register or written it to come back to
it later with the same packet you sort
of have to leave behind you some
something and something lying in wait
for the next packet but it's very hard
to do repeat operations on the same data
the amount of memory involved is quite
modest and there's a simple ALU a simple
I'll use associated with action
processing but you can do very simple
computation simple if-then-else
processing addition subtraction not
division you know etc so again a very
very primitive computational model so
the question we looked at was sort of a
very natural one to think about which is
have heavy-hitter or detection in my
network there might be tens of thousands
of flows going through it all
conversations taking place independently
I want to know the K largest or the ones
that are exceeding a particular rate of
sending and the challenge is I don't
have memory to store state about every
flow so there in the theory literature
is a very simple algorithm it's a very
natural algorithm for doing this called
the space savings algorithm essentially
what you do is you store a key value
table the key is let's say an identifier
the flow this could be the source IP
address or source destination pair or
whatever your defined a flow as and the
value is a count of the number of
packets or the number of bytes that have
been seen for this flow so far and the
goal is to identify only those above a
threshold or only those that are the
biggest and so the basic idea in the
space savings algorithm is if a key
comes in that's already in the table you
just increment its count if the table is
not full and a new key comes in you put
it in and if the table is full and you
have to evict something you evict what
would you expect you would have victim
key with the minimum value right because
that's the one least likely to be
significant down the road and so you
would find key five with a value of one
and you would evict it to make room for
key so that's it yeah that's sort of the
basic algorithm this does not work in
the computational model I mentioned for
a bunch of reasons the first of all it
requires an order and scan of the table
to find the current minimum which isn't
going to be free is it feasible we
really want to do one read or a small
number of reads and writes in each stage
of the table processing so we can't do
this so it's going to walk you through a
succession of some simple ideas are
gonna each be natural but at the end
they turn into a solution that can run
in in one of these switches so the first
idea very simple one is that you would
not need to look at the entire table to
find the true minimum if you got kind of
close to the minimum that would probably
be good enough so let's look at D
entries in the table rather than all n
of them that's a simple case let's
suppose it's two then when the key comes
in you might apply two hash functions to
the key look at two different locations
in the memory and recognize well one of
these is the smaller of the two I'll
leave it that it's not perfect I would
have loved to have evicted key five but
I didn't know about it because I
happened not to pick it but the hope is
that you would do a reasonably good job
not evicting one of the true heavy
hitters if you applied a technique like
that now even that is not ideal because
it does multiple memory accesses at a
time so a simple extension of this idea
is to make this table actually multiple
tables one per stage in the pipeline of
processing so a packet would now have a
single read and write in a single entry
in each stage so you might let's a hash
the key here and recognize that key two
can be should be evicted and then and
then and then we have a problem though
because if I were to go through multiple
stages of processing and look at key two
and key four and then
compute the minimum I don't have the
luxury of circulating back to update the
table entry that has the true minimum in
it I only know the minimum of these d
things when I get to the end of the
processing and I don't have the luxury
without great efficiency to route the
packet back through again a second time
to be able to actually do the updates to
evict the true minimum I don't know at
the beginning this is going to actually
be the minimum because I haven't looked
at the rest of the tables so the final
solution we came up with essentially
does the computation of the minimum in a
rolling fashion in along the pipeline
rather than doing any recirculation the
basic idea is this I come in with a key
I look I evict the first entry gee that
was a huge mistake that's actually the
biggest flow in the system so I really
don't want to evict it but that's okay
I'm going to carry it along to the next
stage where it has a chance to compete
with whatever entry it hashes to and
it'll compete now and recognize well I'm
bigger than key four with a value of two
and so that's the one that gets evicted
so essentially by processing each packet
once in each stage reading and writing
one entry in each stage and passing a
little metadata from one step to the
next can essentially evict something
close to the true minimum even though
it's not exactly right so just to think
about how this matches the computational
model I talked about earlier we're
essentially storing these tables in the
register arrays that I showed you
earlier we're using a simple arithmetic
logic unit to do a sum hash function on
the packet header we're using simple
logic to do conditional updates to
compute the minimum and we're using
small amount of metadata to pass along
with the real packet information about
its key or about a key that's been
evicted at a previous stage of
processing for this packet and then the
nice thing is that even though this is
not exactly the space savings algorithm
from the theory literature in practice
we do really close in terms of the
overhead and performance that one one
would get for using that algorithm so so
that's sort of a little deep dive into
one example problem what we'd really
like to do is come up with a more
general way of thinking about this
computational model and what kinds of
questions can be answered efficiently
using it but in terms of the lessons
here one is just getting at the
beginning super concrete defining a very
simple computational model inspired by
the capabilities of new hardware a
simple example problem that has a
strawman solution that's been heavily
studied in the theory literature and
then iteratively relaxing that does
based on that constraints that the
hardware imposes but of course we have a
long way to go we'd like to have
provable bounds on accuracy that
something we lack for this solution
right now we have some sort of simple
analysis that helps us get inside but
it's not a not a very tight bound on
performance and we'd like to have a more
general way to approach a broader set of
analysis questions using techniques of
this type so it's sort of the the third
piece of work and I think it's going to
end with a few minutes of thoughts about
interdisciplinary work and when I first
gave this talk for the Athena lecture it
was two at large the academic community
where I think I was trying to sell
people on the merits of
interdisciplinary work I'm at a place
here where you guys do that all the time
so it indulge me for a moment on a few
thoughts about lessons about that I know
I'm sort of preaching preaching to the
choir
so I firstly find interdisciplinary work
you know intellectually really exciting
you learn about other areas and perhaps
the more surprising things you learn
about your own area when you have to
explain it to someone else who's a
natural skeptic and maybe not naturally
passionate about the minutiae of your
field and so it becomes a nice way to
learn how to articulate your own field
to other people and often real problems
are inherently interdisciplinary so it's
also as part of a broader hope for for
impact on the field of IT in general
it's a nice style of work to do and
frankly it's actual just a lot of fun
I've gotten to know each of the people I
mentioned in these three collaborations
really well and sometimes the fun
doesn't involve work sometimes they're
kind of sores of fine wine and food as
well so but if you thought particularly
for younger people in the field one
thing was lesson you might get from this
talk is that I've done a little bit of
work in network optimization a little
work in programming languages a little
bit of work in compact data structures
and in fact I've really done very little
work in any of those because I work a
lot with collaborators who had expertise
in those in other areas so I've been
pretty opportunistic if someone will
play with me and they have a hammer
that's relevant to the problems I work I
say yes that's not always the right way
to go in particular they can be merit in
honing one's own single hammer to use on
a range of problems particularly for
grad students or people early in their
career it gives you a way to control
your fate and to do work without being
dependent on a collaborator at all times
although it requires a little bit of
care because you end up having to pick
that hammer very wisely because we
coming an expert takes a lot of time and
you want to make sure if that hammer is
useful for a wide range of problems in
your field not just one you can do what
I did which is to work by collaboration
the riskier for junior folks but it can
be okay if you can define a niche for
yourself involving digging really deep
into crystallizing models of what the
computational capabilities are of the
devices in your own field and that sort
of where or I've tried to walk the line
between deeply understanding the
capabilities below me and the network
administrative tasks above me and
translate those into terms that other
people in other fields can think about
but it's a bit more of a nebulous skill
set than being an expert in a particular
disciplinary domain so it's certainly
something to to do with caution there
can also be a pretty steep learning
curve many of these projects I just
mentioned where multi-year efforts
before anything happened that was
interesting because often there's a lot
of time taken to to learn the language
of both of the two different fields and
the two different cultures and in some
cases it can be easier in one direction
than the other or just am I in working
with programming languages colleagues
have certainly found it's been easier to
get programming languages students to do
great work in networking than the other
way around because Piell has you know
many years of training and a lot of
aesthetic involved in it that can be
very hard to train in the short period
of time different subsets of networking
can themselves be challenging but
they're often teams who learn more
incrementally as you go and you can
often do interesting work without
knowing everything about networking
so I've certainly found that it's
sometimes easier to go from the hammer
towards the nail than the other way
around and one way to walk that line is
to join an existing community of people
and you know pls networking PL
intersection is an example of that now
where there's already some technical
foundation software stacks models to
think of of course it's always with some
recipes if you join a party too late
it's not necessarily as interesting but
sometimes there can be the beginnings of
a new community and that afford an
opportunity to do new work without doing
all the heavy lifting yourself one thing
I hear a lot from people is credit how
does this work you know when you're
publishing in two different venues and
there's many authors on papers and I
would just say a couple lessons there
I've worked with a number in this
project with a number of junior
collaborators and clearly one way to
walk that line is to publish where it's
appropriate for the junior collaborator
so that there's they're not taking the
risk that you no longer have to worry
about taking and and also understanding
the evaluation processes at one's own
institution so you know whether whether
the work that's done with multiple
senior or multiple faculty co-authors
will be valued in the in the tenure
evaluation process and finally I'll just
note that this sometimes
interdisciplinary work can make this
problem easier if I write a paper with
Nate even when he was a relatively
junior colleague it was really really
obvious which work was in which work was
mine because there's just stuff in the
paper that I could never have done
myself that I barely understand now if
he was working with a PL call colleague
is a little less clear and likewise if
I'm working with the junior networking
person it could be a little less clear
who's bringing what to the table but
with interdisciplinary work it's often
pretty easy to tell whose fingerprints
are on which parts of the work exactly
you can go and go yeah I remember
colleague John Feigenbaum I'm sure you
know once said to me she said networking
papers are weird they have a lot of text
so there's treats I did I did the text
so I think another piece is healthy
interdisciplinary collaborations can be
challenging I only talked about three
projects that were at least it's sent to
some degree successful there are tons of
projects I chose not to talk about
because they weren't and reasons they
weren't successful often collaborators
don't stick together you know there's a
relationship that requires a nurturing
and and also people that are willing to
dig in for a long period of time before
something interesting happens and the
bottom line is sometimes the work isn't
actually interesting in both fields or
if there can be an expertise I need to
get my job done but if that work is not
interesting intellectually to the other
person because it's sort of routined
run-of-the-mill that's not going to be a
lasting collaboration unless they really
have a lot of patience for tech transfer
yeah even when it is exciting sometimes
it's hard to convince the people in your
field like like in on the intersection
like if you're drilling to publish and
pop all the people who review the papers
look at the pop up results and they're
not they don't know I'm networking so
they don't really understand fully what
the challenges are how hard it is so I
think there's a certain amount of like
just assuming that you know if it's like
this collaboration
it's a weaker form of the same kind of
thing yeah yeah and particularly the
work with hmong that ended up being an
issue on the optimization work I talked
about at the beginning because
networking conferences would read it and
be like oh there's like scary math in it
and then the optimization venues would
be like oh this is like standard
optimization Theory records we're trying
to pick problem formulations that were
amenable to a simple math simple math
you know for the optimization folks
right as we wanted everything to be come
back so we could do you know
optimization decomposition but in my own
community there's like Greek in it so
they're like oh I don't know what you
guys are up to it seems a little weird
so that definitely had some issues
because of the differences in value
structure and in fact another piece of
that is some communities value you know
proofs and some value code and not many
value both and so if you want paper to
have both if you want to sort of make
the more applied people and the more
theoretical people happy that can
certainly be a challenge and at a
minimum the collaborators need a shared
a union of each other's values if you
will our union of their fields values to
be able to make that work and of course
engaging students and postdocs I found
this is actually generally pretty good
and this episode students often are
excited about interdisciplinary work
because it's exciting it's a little
risky but it's it's unique and gives
them a niche to be in but it does
require more training and more patience
and wrangling two or more advisers which
is always a challenge of a non-technical
nature as well and finally I know this
is gonna sound kind of weird for an
internet researcher to say but I'm a big
fan of physical proximity this kind of
work all happens in person all of it the
unsuccessful projects were a mix of
in-person and not but it's just super
hard when two faculty members or two
researchers really need to have air time
with one another it's just very very
difficult to have those early stages of
collaboration take place not in person
this is work for me work with me
remotely when a student does an
internship and I certainly have many
successful projects at Microsoft of this
type where students spent a summer or
longer at Microsoft and made made the
bridges stronger to make that possible
but for projects where it's like two
faculty members at different
institutions working it's it's just kind
of a bloodbath because people just you
know out of sight out of mind and it's
just hard to talk on skype or hangouts
all the time so I'll just conclude by
saying you know computer networking is
I've always found it a very exciting
area of research because it's a rich
space of important practical problems
that affect real people's lives and as
an intellectually rich space of really
hard problems and the sort of general
grand challenge of building networks
worthy of the trust society increasingly
puts in them is is intellectually
enriching and has really I think
potential for a lot of practical value
but it definitely I think requires
ability to bridge across the divides
with some of these neighboring
disciplines within computer science and
elsewhere
to make it happen so thanks for your
attention I'm also happy to take
questions manifold hammer so know you
only know what hammer you need after you
decide what you do amok yeah I'm up
curious about in this year how you build
up your vision and how do you decide
which part which direction is better
than the other so you jump yeah I think
I think in particular for the first two
projects I've always been interested in
resource optimization questions a lot of
the work I did at AT&T was about
optimizing resources and about the pain
network administrators felt in getting
their networks to do what they wanted so
optimization and pl they just sort of
jump out as hey there's pain around
resource optimization and around
expression and it became sort of natural
to think of those two fields and then I
think recently with these new emerging
hardware devices it's really clear that
that it's running a streaming algorithm
with limited storage and computation and
so then you're like oh that's you know
that's compact data structures so I
think for those three particular
projects it was sort of natural I think
could be harder in other areas but I
think it's not a coincidence that those
particular problems were born out of
networking people are always preoccupied
with problems of scarcity right and
problems a scarcity really benefit from
algorithms and optimization so that's
just like our bread and butter and the
PL stuff is a little more of a stretch
because I've never taken a PL course if
I should never taken a networking course
either for that matter absolutely - but
in fact actually some of my colleagues
who are more disparaging of networking
think that might be why I stayed in the
field that if I don't they take in a
networking course I might think
differently about the field but yes I
think some of it is that those are sort
of the most natural collaborations like
the arocs points about game theory and
economics I think that's an area that's
natural - but that's tougher because I
think it's a it's a it's a bigger reach
I think for networking people who don't
already have some of that background or
some of these some of these stay within
CS and I do think they're started be a
more vibrant sort of mechanism design
and algorithmic game theory community
within CS but before that built up I
think it was actually really hard is
there's an even bigger gap to talk to an
economist like what is that I don't even
know how to do it yeah the one thing I
think is interesting about this
relationship you TPL networking is
there's sort of the history appeal and
and hardware design and they and then
that evolved over the decades and then
you know the networking community
certains saw that there was a potential
opportunity there's a similar
relationship but they had all that
history sister to quickly move up and
and get you know on par with and I said
I think it's really it's exciting to see
the kind of rapid development of these
ideas and how they get a apply to
practice yeah I think part of that going
back to the points that Victor was
making was because there was an
inflection point in the networking
community with cloud with merchants
silicon chip sets that changed the
nature of the question so it was
possible to build on top of something
that it wasn't there before it's
actually very correct for example just I
think you saw my blog I wrote recently
yeah I think it's it's things are
getting so complicated and it's so
complex in here you know we live
actually a very pristine world in some
sense whenever we kids are thinking
clear things I just had lunch with a
friend and the other side and I was sort
of explained to me the other side
[Laughter]
dealing with that complexity I mean what
it's really it's always a firefighting
trip it's not stopped like you know how
much capacity do you have you know how
do you sort of like move vm's around or
you know how do you sort of like and
that was actually and things go down all
the time the problem is that if one up
like as you know one Crowder goes down
once which goes down into a new master
section of the cloud come down which
means all these properties everything
comes down so as as we progress is
becoming even more clearer than we
should have done this right in the first
place which is that we should not have
hacked it all together the way we've
acted all together we should have had
some sort of discipline in the way we
did you know we took concepts of
programming and so this is what's going
on in there
now for example I think the other
important thing point about cloud is a
lot of the cloud companies Microsoft
included the network is just one piece
of the infrastructure and in every other
part of the infrastructure you're
allowed to like write your own code and
touch the code is somehow the network is
sacrosanct and like the network's in the
way and you can't fix it all right and
so people are just defended where I
think if you work at a networking
company that's just so normal to you but
if you're in a company then we're
networking is just one of many pieces
that's just such an anatomist but what I
wanted to see was so that is that will
keep us busy for a while
there's no question about it but still
there are other aspects to things still
linked for example you know latency is a
big thing latency is the first line
moving faster and faster we don't really
know why the speed we can get it we
don't like that why can't we move
packets aren't fast enough to actually
be able to get to them so there are all
these other things that require it but
the balance is like where our attention
is right now I thought the whole
community seemed to have that intention
of when you get to things like Lindsay
and all the areas of don't quite have a
clarity on what interdisciplinary sort
of stuff can help there so one things
have not worked on that seems very
natural also his control theory I mean I
talked a lot about control loops in this
talk but I've actually never
collaborated with someone in control
theory and that seems like that seems
like a missing link as well where I
think the networking committee their
handful of people who do like you know
like Mohammed ELISA did a mighty
certainly has done a lot of work
including work he did here that has that
that taste inna kitabi so they certainly
people who do it but I think that's an
under explored area networking for sure
because everything we do is control
loops and complex interacting ones and
when they interact in ways you don't
understand all hell breaks loose
any other comments questions great
thanks so much
[Applause]